when I did the OSI I think I just got to
the point where I was like I'm not sure
I'm enjoying this anymore
that's Mischa Barton opening up on this
week's Dancing with the Stars about her
time as Marissa Cooper on the OSI
revealing why she needed a break from
Hollywood after she left the show I just
felt like I was in a machine and I
couldn't really get off so it was time
to like step back so I went back to
England and it was just a year of real
self exploration her OC co-star Peter
Gallagher showed his support for the
actress by praising her tenacity
overnight fame can kill you I have an
idea of the journey that she's been on
and some of the challenges she's had and
just the fact that she is still showing
up you know does my heart good he says
something pretty powerful he said like
overnight Fame can really kill you would
you agree with that statement Peter and
I know each other really quite well BOC
was like an overnight success and I was
the youngest of everyone on the cast at
that time so I think he understood
better than anyone what my what my
journey was Misha Samba earned her her
highest scores and remarks from the
judges yet but still it wasn't enough to
keep her and partner ornaments of around
they were eliminated from the
competition was this experience what you
thought that it would be going into it
it's it was definitely maybe more than I
had bargained for in a lot of ways it
was um but you know again it's like I'm
so happy I tried something that's that
foreign to me you wish America had
gotten to see more of you a little yeah
I mean I do I think we could have gone
on for like another week or so at least
you know but like hey it wasn't meant to
be